starting today if you're fully
vaccinated
and you're outdoors you need and not in
a big crowd
you no longer need to wear a mask i want
to be absolutely clear
if you're in a crowd like a stadium or
at a conference
or a concert you still
need to wear a mask even if you're
outside
the bottom line is clear if you're
vaccinated
you can do more things more safely
both outdoors as well as indoors
it's a breath of fresh air president
biden in the cdc delivering some
game-changing new guidance on mask fully
vaccinated individuals can ditch them
while outdoors but if you're in a
crowded setting you need to put them
back on
it's the most significant change to
recommendations since the lockdowns
began
over a year ago and the administration
is hoping
that it will encourage more americans to
get vaccinated
but as we know in politics optics is
everything and biden is getting called
out for walking to the podium
while wearing his mask outside to
deliver the announcement
take a look what message were you
sending by wearing a mask outside alone
and watching me take it off and not put
it back on till i get inside
dana you're a master of optics uh i
don't know i
have two questions for you what'd you
think of that what was that a big deal
too well i think it's look it's welcome
news
i think it's late in coming i think they
could have done this a long time ago i
think many of the states are well ahead
of where the cdc is
and i do feel like this look i'm not
saying that they don't have challenges
in terms of
a public health crisis i get that but i
feel like the communications on this
continues to be botched every time you
turn around they'll say
one thing for example you'll remember
the cdc said schools can be open
and then four days later it's like well
actually schools can't be open well why
what happened between them
the only thing i can think of is that
it's politics because it wasn't like new
science
came forward and said schools can't be
open and
kids are spreading it that didn't happen
so i'm hoping that people will take this
um as red i noticed today when i walked
um
from my apartment to here uh people that
were fully vaccinated
no one's wearing masks we're all like
walking around and so
maybe it will give people the confidence
they need or incentive
in order to do that but right now i feel
like
you know they've botched so much of the
communications over and over again
that uh this i don't know maybe people
won't believe it or
they'll maybe continue to listen to
state officials who have already said
you don't have to wear a mask when
you're outside and vaccinated
the last thing is on the optics i mean
that was a really good point
why are you if you're going out there to
make a statement about how you
can be without a mask if you're fully
vaccinated
why are you walking up there like that
but that's the one that took
takes the cake was when he wore the mask
during the zoom meeting
at the climate summit when you're by
yourself in a zoom
i'm pretty sure you do not need to read
a map wear a mask and i'm
not i don't think you have to ask the
cdc about that i just think that's
common sense
all right so dagon you know another way
to look at this
is biden winning uh this war against the
virus i was thinking to myself we were
worried a few weeks ago about a
coming fourth wave but now it looks like
with the vaccines
really everybody getting vaccinated i
think more than half now
of the eligible americans for a vaccine
have had at least the first shot
is it the case that we can say that the
vaccines are winning out and biden
as president therefore is winning this
big fight
the american people are winning the war
period and
the biden biden code need to do more to
encourage
people to go out and get those vaccines
22 percent in that fox news poll said
that they didn't plan to get it
so what did they do today they came out
and told the american people they could
do
something that they've been doing for
the last year
without being vaccinated because
transmission
outside is rare incredibly rare so what
are they doing to say
hey you really don't need to go get
vaccinated you can do this
they need to come out i was emailing
with a very prominent doctor
if you've been vaccinated they should
come out and say you can be surrounded
by other people who've been vaccinated
inside you can go eat dinner you can be
inside someone's home you can go to a
party that it's the
right now case numbers and
hospitalizations
are low like a mild flu in this country
so where are we with this i just think
that this is a reluctance to give away
power accumulated in government over the
last year
why do it in dribs and drabs there's
still more than half the states have
public mass mandates in place get rid of
them
get rid of them let them again are they
going to be neanderthals too absolutely
the only thing that's going to come out
of this announcement today is surely
some
left-wing lunatics are going to start
picking fights with people who are out
in the street
not wearing masks they're the
self-appointed shame police
these screeching pod people
demanding proof of your vaccine it's
going to be a nightmare
in new york all right